JELENA MIJUSKOVIC: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jelena.
DEOK FILHO: And I'm Deok.
And we're both customer
engineers at Google Cloud.
JELENA MIJUSKOVIC: Welcome
back to the technical series
for startups, where we're
creating a series of videos
for technical enablement to
help startups to start, build,
and grow their businesses
successfully and sustainably
in Google Cloud.
DEOK FILHO: In the
previous video,
we deep dived into automating
your development lifecycle
with CI and CD pipelines.
And now, we'll talk about how
to improve the performance
and reliability of
your applications
with Cloud operations.
JELENA MIJUSKOVIC:
In this video,
we're going to
cover introduction
to the Cloud operation
suite, formerly known
as Tech Driver, Operation tools
as means to have observability
over your Google
Cloud resources,
application
performance management
tools to improve
performance and reliability
of your applications.
Finally, we'll share a
customer success story
to demonstrate the value of the
Google Cloud Operation Suite.
If you've ever worked with
on-premises environment,
you know that, if your
application becomes
unresponsive, somebody could
walk in, physically check why,
and resolve the issue.
In the cloud, though,
how do you know
what's happening with
your server, database,
or application?
The answer is simple,
with the tools that we
will show you in this video.
Capturing of telemetry,
login, and trace data
is done from the hardware layer
and app for Google products.
From these products, signal
data flows into Cloud Operation
tools, where it
can be visualized
in dashboards and through
the metrics explorer.
Automated and custom logs
can be ingested and analyzed
in the log viewer.
Services can be
monitored for compliance
with the service-level
objectives.
And error budgets
can be tracked.
Health checks can be used
to check uptime and latency
for external-facing
sites and services.
And running applications can
be debugged and profiled.
When incident is
secure, single data
can generate
automated alerts that
can notify personnel through
various notification channels.
Error reporting can help
operation and developer teams
to spot, count,
and analyze crashes
in your cloud-based services.
Finally, all the visualization
and analysis tools
can help to troubleshoot what is
happening in your Google Cloud
environment.
Let's start first with
exploring the products that
tend to be of interest
for the operation folks.
Cloud Logging provides a
centralized Cloud Logging
system that you can use
to store, search, analyze,
monitor, and alert log data and
events from all Google Cloud
resources but also
to collect data
from multicloud environments
with Anthos integration.
Cloud Logging also
provides integration
into third-party systems through
the API and Cloud Pub/Sub.
The export
functionality allows you
to perform aggregated
analytics in BigQuery
and store your logs in
Google Cloud Storage.
As you can see from
this quick demo,
with features like histogram,
Logs Field Explorer,
you can quickly gain insights
into trends across your logs.
Error reporting provides
insights into your errors
by collecting and grouping
your application errors.
There are three
key log categories,
audit logs, agent
logs, and network logs.
Audit logs help answer the
question, who did what,
where, and when?
And those are admin activity
logs, data access logs,
system event, and data
transparency logs.
Agent logs use a Google
customized and packaged Fluentd
agent that can be installed
on any Google Cloud or AWS VM
instance and ingest logs
from Google Cloud or AWS EC2
instance.
Finally, network logs provide
in-depth network telemetry
with PPC flow logs,
firewall rules, NAT gateway,
and load balancer types.
Cloud Monitoring allows
you to collect metrics
from multicloud and hybrid
infrastructure in real time.
By using cloud
monitoring, you can
answer important questions like,
what is the load on my service?
Is my website
responding correctly?
Is my service performing well?
To understand the
current load on a service
or to view performance
data of your service
for the past month, use the
charts and dashboard tools.
If you're interested
in being notified
if your deployed
service isn't accessible
or responding correctly, then
configure an uptime check
and attach an alerting policy.
This is an example of
Metrics Explorer, where
you can explore metric
lists for all GCP services
and add them to
different chart types.
Monitoring has many
predefined metric types
and monitored
resources available.
But you can also
create custom metrics.
If you don't want to save the
chart to a custom dashboard
but you want to keep a
reference to the chart,
then save the chart URL.
Dashboards are one way for
you to view and analyze
metric data.
The Cloud Console provides
15 predefined dashboards
that require no setup
or configuration.
Your Google Cloud
project resources
determine the dashboards
available for you.
For example, if your project
contains Compute Engine
instances, then your
project includes dashboards
for VM instances and for disks.
DEOK FILHO: Hey, everyone.
The next step is
for us to check out
some tools to help you manage
your application's performance.
At the heart of measuring
application performance
in Google Cloud
lies Cloud Debugger.
It lets you inspect the state
of a running application
in real time without
stopping your application
or slowing it down,
all at no cost.
With Cloud Debugger, you can
examine your code's function
and performance under actual
production conditions.
How convenient is that?
In addition to
real-time app debugging,
Cloud Debugger
allows you to capture
the state of your application
in production at a specific line
location with snapshots.
You can see this on the right.
I first set up a
snapshot at line 73.
You can see, in the
snapshot column,
that it's waiting for a change.
I then go to my application
and provoke a state change
by clicking the
Add to Cart button.
You can immediately see the
state capture by the snapshot,
specifically, that the cost
ID variable, set at line 73,
has the value undefined.
Moving on from snapshots,
you can also use log points
to inject a new logging
statement on demand
at a specific line location,
as well as capture a snapshot
or write a log
point message only
when you need it using a simple
conditional expression written
in your application's language.
The ease of use
of Cloud Debugger
is further extended
by its integration
with existing developer
workflows and popular IDEs.
You can easily collaborate
with other teams
by sharing your debug session.
In this demo, I can simply
share my console URL
with a team member.
And they'll be able to see
the snapshot I created.
Debugger also knows how to
display the correct version
of your source code
because it easily
integrates with
the version control
systems such as cloud
source repositories, GitHub,
Bitbucket, or GitLab.
Now that we've seen
how easy and convenient
it is to work with
Debugger, let me tell you
what Cloud Trace is.
Based on the tools that Google
itself uses on its production
services, Cloud Trace is a
tracing system that collects,
analyzes, and
displays latency data
from your distributed
applications and displays
that in the Google
Cloud console.
Cloud Trace can capture traces
from applications deployed
on App Engine, Compute Engine
VMs, and Kubernetes Engine
containers.
It generates performance
insights near real time
and automatically generates
in-depth latency reports.
Finally, Cloud Trace
also continuously gathers
and analyzes trace data
to automatically identify
recent changes to your
application's performance.
Let me show you a quick
demo of Cloud Trace.
First, when opening Cloud Trace
in the Google Cloud console,
I immediately see an
overview of previous traces
and report of latency.
Let's navigate to
the trace list page.
I'll create some
filters to see calls
to a currency service
of my application
that are only
getting get requests
which took at least 1,000
milliseconds from request
to response.
I then select a
trace from the graph.
And below, in the
trace waterfall view,
I can explore the spans,
which are suboperations
of this particular trace.
Finally, under
the Details panel,
I select to View Logs, which
takes me to the Cloud Logging
page, where I can see detailed
log entries associated
with the request that
initiated this trace.
In summary, this
allows you to see
how requests propagate through
services in separate projects
and helps you to identify
sources of poor performance
across your entire stack.
On to error reporting, error
reporting counts, analyzes,
and aggregates the crashes in
your running cloud services.
A dedicated view shows the
error details, time chart,
occurrences, affected
user count, first
and last seen dates, and a
cleaned exception stack trace.
You can opt in to receive
email and mobile alerts
on new errors.
Finally, the last
major component
of measuring your application's
performance is Cloud Profiler.
Poorly performing code
increases the latency and cost
of applications in web services
every day without anyone
knowing or doing
anything about it.
To solve it, Cloud
Profiler continuously
analyzes the performance
of CPU-intensive and
memory-intensive functions
across an application
Cloud Profiler does this by
using statistical techniques
and extremely low-impact
instrumentation
that runs across all production
application instances
to provide a complete CPU and
heat picture of an application
without slowing it down.
To set up Cloud
profiler, you first
include a language-specific
profiling agent
in your application.
Whether it is running in GC
EVMs, App Engine, or GKE,
the agent then collects
profiling data as the app runs.
As you can see from
the image on the right,
Cloud Profiler presents the
call hierarchy and resource
consumption of the
relevant function
and an interactive
flame graph that
helps developers understand
which paths consume the most
resources and the different ways
in which their code is actually
called.
Now that you've seen many
operations in application
performance
management tools, how
should you use them to bring
your ideas to market faster
and to be more responsive
to your customers?
Well, Google's Site Reliability
Engineering, or SRE,
is the answer.
SRE is how operations at
Google adopted DevOps.
The five SRE design principles
redefine reliability,
reduce oil, balance speed
and risk, make small changes
and create the
right culture, help
you accomplish these goals.
The tools we introduced
were designed
based on Google's own operations
experience and development
of SRE practices.
A key area of practice
for SRE is monitoring.
Cloud Monitoring, which pulls
data from multiple sources,
not only gives you
the visibility you
need to quickly
determine service health
and diagnose your applications
when things go wrong, but also
addresses the fundamental
monitoring needs of SRE,
with components such
as SLO monitoring,
dashboards, and its analytics
capabilities through default
and custom metrics.
Let me tell you about a
customer success story.
Krikey is a gaming
company, which
aims to bring the excitement
of interacting with characters
through augmented
reality by leveraging
stories that are rarely
told in mainstream gaming.
With four separate games,
all requiring multiple video
feeds, they rely
on Cloud Operations
to monitor, troubleshoot, and
improve their application's
performance.
In particular, the Cloud
Monitoring dashboard
gives them deep visibility
into latency, downtime,
and the overall health
of their applications.
Here is a joint quote
from Krikey's CEO and CTO.
"Having one integrated view of
alerts, SLOs, events, and logs
via the dashboard, which
allows us to quickly identify
which container has the
problem, fix the container,
and redeploy."
JELENA MIJUSKOVIC: In
this episode today,
you got to see the
fundamental components
in making your
application perform better
with a consistent and effortless
observability and monitoring
of your resources.
Thank you for joining us on this
episode about Cloud Operations.
To continue exploring,
check out our suggestions
on the links in the description.
We'll see you next
time for an overview
of billing, a critical component
of your Google Cloud presence.
You will learn about
different discounting options,
how billing works, and
how to manage your costs.
Don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube channel
and to click on the bell icon
to get notified each time we
post a new video.
See you next time.
DEOK FILHO: Bye, bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]